thank you for coming I'll just leave
this up for another minute in case
anybody wants to download the slides
there's only one directory in there
since a new repo so not actually
expecting anyone to run the examples but
if you want to follow along it's it's
useful so my name is ryan i work at in
the engineering group at y hat by day
it's pronounced y hat not yet not Y hat
hat we've heard them all we do data
science infrastructure collaboration
tools and things like that we have a
really cool blog and some cool products
so check us out if you don't know us
cool stuff by night I'm a PhD student in
operations research eternally working on
my dissertation if that sort of fills
you in any on what the topic is going to
be like a little bit in here this is
going to be a little different from some
of the talks at PI data in that there's
actually not going to be a whole lot of
data in here there will be some data but
the purpose of this model is partly to
show like how complex decisions can be
made using Python and open source tools
like that so I'm you don't necessarily
need to understand all of the modeling
components that go into this a few
salient points are that one we don't
need big data to have intractability we
can make problems very hard with very
small amounts of data in fact we're
practically practically surrounded by
intractability almost all the time but
second that intractability is not a
death sentence we regularly solve hard
models and get useful answers out of
them sometimes even optimal solutions to
problems and that third the one of the
things that makes things either very
easy or very hard for modelers is the
interplay of data and structure and so
the the problem we're going to look at
today while it may not be particularly
interesting to you I think it's very
interesting structurally because it
gives us sort of techniques or shows
techniques on approaching a problem that
is otherwise very hard so we'll start by
setting the scene a little bit
who of you knows or feels like you have
a good idea of what DevOps is raise your
hands who knows what it stands for I
actually don't know what it stands for
what it is okay all right so I think of
Scotty as sort of the archetypal devops
engineer he's constantly putting out
fires you know somebody uh you know
forgot to you know test their code or
something and just stuck it into
production and then the Machine goes
down or or oh gosh you know someone
unplug the network cable and the box
just catches on fire or you know
somebody just keeps trying to ram their
random forest model into memory even
though they know it won't fit they call
on Scotty to fix that for them but one
of the more important things is that
Scotty maintains all the environments in
a hardware that our IT infrastructure
depends on so that is one of the
fundamental roles of DevOps is creation
of environments for building your
software for testing your software for
distributing your software and for
running it in production we we could not
do much of anything that we do without
DevOps and especially when it comes to
cloud computing DevOps is claiming an
even more important role there's even a
Venn diagram about it and we all know
how much we love Venn diagrams here this
is the sign of a true professional I
mean you know like the data science diet
Venn diagram you can sort of overlay it
and here we have the DevOps diagram but
it is it is pretty much the culmination
of software engineering QA and
technology operations that is a pretty
good description I think of what DevOps
does so let's consider a typical day in
the life of the devops engineer you're
working on a java project at yet another
enterprise java application running on
enterprise software company we all know
that Java makes lots of money so that's
a cool thing but then not on a
shell-shocked comes out or some other
utility needs to be upgraded you can't
just take your application and run it on
new systems without testing it so you
now need two environments the first
environment is the existing production
environment where you install your job
application or I'm sorry java compiler
and runtime environment you download all
the dependencies and libraries that it
needs to run on and then you set up your
database the second environment is all
those same things so we're going to call
these commands a B and C with an
additional command D
which is to upgrade that underlying
system utility whatever it is so now I
have two environments that I need one is
my testing environment one is my
production environment if my testing
environment passes tests i'm going to
switch it over to production and then
we'll be good oh i forgot i also need to
integrate with postgres and my sequel
and [ __ ] and myself three runs on
redhat and it runs on centos and it runs
on ubuntu so as I add these things I
have more structure and more
environments that I need to test in and
the problem with that is that it's not
additive its multiplicative right if I'm
really thorough I need to test in every
single combination of these things and
so my devops engineer is gonna be
working all weekend probably looking for
a new job if you've been in IT long
enough or you work for the organization
sort of organization that has a room
like this you remember that before cloud
computing we all had these rooms that
were overly air-conditioned where we
kept all of our hardware and its really
I mean it's still like this right i mean
at some fundamental level when you go on
to the cloud and you ask for a computer
it's still just somebody else's computer
sitting a server rack like this right
like the magic of cloud computing is
that it's available to you all the time
but still somebody has to go into a room
or something has to install an operating
system or at least a hypervisor on a
machine maintain it make sure that it
doesn't fail have it network the great
way so on so forth a lot of time or a
lot of the way that people would would
create fresh environments for testing
and development back in the day where
they would they would go and they would
take their installation media and let's
say you were going to operate Oracle
you'd grab your son OS CD and grab your
Oracle CD and then you put on your
winter coat and then you would walk into
the server room and three hours later
you would emerge with a new freshly
built piece of hardware and this was
really inconvenient right because it
took a long time and you know you you
keep doing that and then you spin your
disk to death and you have to get
another one so what people would do
instead which they they would just
uninstall things and then reinstall it
and hope for the best but that's not
really good either because software
these relics behind so you're sort of in
this catch-22 of it's either going to
take me a really long time and I can be
thorough
it's going to be quick can I can be sort
of not thorough and hope for the best
this is what we do now so this is of
course the doctor whale just running in
a cloud and that's kind of how we think
of DevOps these days right we just spin
up a container it's like oh well there
it is and it sits in a way it's kind of
true I mean every time we spend up a new
container with an image it's like it's
like it's just you know fresh born and
pure as the driven snow it's like
nobody's tampered with it right and
that's kind of awesome so our next topic
is what's a container I've been getting
this these two questions a lot this week
first what stalker and second should i
be using it so i'll tip to ask answer
that the best I can docker is a
container architecture what is a
container architecture it's a
lightweight virtualization platform
there's lots of different kinds of
virtualization if you haven't used dokie
you probably use something like virtual
box and that's a sort of a software
virtualization layer and when I'm when I
use something like virtual box and I
install say ubuntu on VirtualBox what
that is doing in a sense is an actual
install at the operating system on to
virtual hardware so when i boot up and i
use ubuntu inside a virtual box it is as
though i am sitting on the the
installation of the medium or the OS on
hardware and there's a translation layer
right it has its own kernel it has its
own device drivers and and there's
performance degradation to that docker
is a little different and other
containers like lxc container
architectures like LXE are a little
different in that they do not do that
they do not have their own kernel they
don't have their own device drivers they
do not really wrap much they depend on
these functions within the Linux kernel
that allow them to live in their own
namespaces and have their own resources
but not be fully virtualized so when
you're running a docker container it's
as though the docker container thinks
that it's it's own operating system but
it's really not and we'll see that in a
minute when we do a demo so
i am going to grade a docker container
all right should I make a little larger
how's that alright so the IT tells it to
go into interactive mode TTT gives me a
TTYL so that I can actually type things
to it and I'm going to run I'm going to
save my Sid Sid as a container ID so
every time you start a container you get
a new ID and I'm going to run the Ubuntu
trustee image and inside that container
I'm going to run bash so when i run this
it tells me the Dockers not running
sorry yeah so just start talking real
quick okay alright so the the CID file
equals it says when you spin up the
container find its ID and save it to
this file and I'm just doing that for
convenience so that I can show you some
other stuff in a minute so any questions
about that I have the Ubuntu trustee
image downloaded already otherwise it
would just go and download it and we'd
be waiting here for a good 15 minutes
all right so I do this and i'm now
sitting in a bash console and you can
see that I am root and this
weird-looking string here that's not
good well that's part of my container ID
it's a sha right so if i type who am i
I'm route I thaipusam x there's really
only these two processes running so it's
shielded from the rest of the processes
in my operating system if i type cat LSP
release that's the LSB release it thinks
it's ubuntu and this is kind of
interesting because i'm running fedora
right but i can apt-get things so i'm
running a fedora kernel with fedora
device drivers but i have a container
that thinks it's ubuntu and this is
really useful because i can build code
the targets boon to see libraries that
ship with ubuntu 14 onto my fedora box
which won't work otherwise like if I
just build them on fedora and stick them
on you into they'll fail
so I'm exactly it doesn't yep exactly no
there is a dr. Damon that it is talking
to but it's just talking over local unix
socket connection essentially yeah I
downloaded the image and we'll see that
in a minute so I'm just going to what
I'm going to do is I'm going to mess
with this and I'm going to commit those
changes to an image and then we'll we'll
see what happens from there so I'm just
going to just do something crazy i'm
going to remove it move my password file
because you know sometimes you do that
right and yeah i mean i'm going to
create this thing it'll be you know just
a nice way to all right so now okay the
you see from the the root at FC that's
my container i'm going to go back to my
host is my host right at localhost all
right so I've got this one guy running
ecstatic Fineman he seems excited and
what I'm going to do here is I'm going
to look at the differences in that
container how it is changed its all
environment and this is where that
container ID file becomes useful so i
changed the etsy directory i deleted the
etsy password and i added the
ingredients file this is just like this
is like a git diff right exactly and now
i'm not typing using it i'm using docker
dr. commit yeah and i'm going to call
this ryan pi data so nasty thing that it
just gave me is the Shah for my image
and I can go exit from this guy and I
can run
I have no name why is that I deleted my
password file oops right so all the
changes that I made have now been
committed to this new image that is
called a layer so if i go here to my
host machine and I do docker history
rhyanne PI data it will show me that
last changed it 38 seconds ago the
changes are 14 bites this is kind of
nasty okay there we go 14 bytes large
that was that they caught the contents
of that diff and that was based on this
other previous layer which is really
just do blue too trusting so it's a
series of layers each layer is
essentially a diff and under the covers
what it's doing is it's using what's a
union file system that sort of back
tracks through those diffs when I look
for files all right any questions about
docker yes I have a fedora linux machine
here yeah my name doctor if you can run
dr on a mac or windows but you're still
really running a linux kernel like
somewhere because it depends on things
on there so usually what that is like
there's now two levels of virtualization
and it works ok but we we I take try
take a small amount of triumph in the
fact that I've switched all of our devs
to unix or linux alright so back to here
ok so the next second question was
should i be using docker well nah i
don't know i can tell you that at y hat
we use a lot of docker we we build our
software we build our binary
distributions inside of it we use it for
testing we use it for development
because it's much easier just spin up a
my sequel database inside of docker and
give it a fresh schema than it is to
worry about migrating things and if we
change our schema ten times a day we can
just spin up new docker containers with
the first schema and it's very fast we
also use it for production izing
predictive models so we use it in both
sort of development QA and we also use
in production so our science ops product
when you deploy a model to it you
specify the exact
environment that you want to hit to have
IE the version of pandas the version of
CVX soft whatever it wraps those up into
an image which can live in perpetuity so
even if those those modules go away off
of pi PI or content destroys them or
whatever whatever crazy thing happens in
the world you can back up that image and
you will always have it you can always
run your model in that image and we also
use it for our collaboration tool
science cluster um see how much time do
I have probably not enough time to show
that I might show that at the end if I
have enough time but it allows us to
give management of Linux environments to
users as though they were rude on the
system when they're really not they can
install packages they can install python
modules they can do all kinds of things
they can run Jupiter notebooks inside of
containers and then they can share those
environment with other people if they
want so it's a very convenient way of
just packaging up what looks like an
operating system and shipping it around
so there's sort of two points here one
is that containers are about isolation I
can change an image I can do whatever I
want to it and it won't affect my host
operating system unless I do something
weird and it won't affect the other
images inside of docker but they're also
about sharing and that's what we're
coming to next specifically what we're
interested in you remember how we have
all these layers here with their shaw's
we're interested in how we can utilize
that Union filesystem mechanics to make
our DevOps time shorter in constructing
our environments because if we can use
that effectively than we can shorten the
amount of time that it takes to
construct all these environments that we
need which is good all right so let's
talk about how doctor does doc cash
mechanics is this is really what defines
our problem this is our structure so
let's say I'm kind of an odd bird and I
really like revision control systems
that are out of date I spend a lot of
time on sourceforge everyone needs a
hobby all right so I find I found last
week I found somebody was actually using
bizarre and I had an old CB s repository
and I was like oh I just want to muck
around in this so I don't want to
install it on my host operating system
because I want to get it
so I create this docker file and this is
a standard just you know this is how you
do this start this is how you create an
image and are usually so I'm going to
start with ubuntu trustee and I'm going
to just apt-get install bzr and CVS on
to it okay great this is the command
that I used to build it so you can see
here I'm giving it the name of that
docker file that i just created and i'm
going to tag it with RCS one revision
control system image one alright great
so when this build command runs the
first thing that does is it says okay
start with the glue to trustee is your
base and says I've already got that
great the next thing it does is install
it apt-get install its bzr well it
doesn't have that so this time it
actually goes through the whole process
of apt getting and this will take a few
minutes and then it does the same thing
for cps right so there's actually two
layers that i've created here and at the
end of it it tags the last layer as the
image RCS one so now I can go and I can
docker run our cs1 bash see which CVS in
which bzr and you can see that I have
both of them I could enter a container
and I could run CBS if I wanted any
questions about this super all right but
you know now I find like an old RCS
repository right does anybody actually
used RCS yeah okay cool I don't was it
actually the first revision control
system I mean it stands for revision
control system okay it means like CVS
without networking essentially right
like first there was RCS time there was
CBS with networking then there were
atomic check-ins on subversion and then
there was distribution on mercurial and
this other thing that Prime's with what
I say what I try to use it sprung up and
everybody seems to be using that now but
anyway so I find like an RCS repository
I want to try so I'm going to add that
to my image all right so I'm going to
create a new image called RCS to and the
first three commands of my daugher file
are the same but I'm now adding these
four commands that allow me to add RCS
because I find like a PPA for it right
so what should happen so I built this
guy and the first three commands it says
I've already done this before I'm not
going to do it again dr. cash
now it gets to the the new steps and
says I haven't done these things before
I'm going to run these commands so these
layers are then added to the darker
cassius it does them and at the end of
this i have a new image which i can run
CBS RCS and bzr it okay so now if I
rebuild the same image we'll see what
happens is every single step it's using
the docker cash I don't have to do any
of it again right so this sort of gets
to the point like if I can structure
these if I have a bunch of these files
and I structure them correctly then I
can share a lot of this computing time
yes space in computing time that's
really it it saves on those things yeah
if you if you had to if you had to get
to have a flat image for every docker
image it would be too much disk space
there wouldn't be enough in the world
all right so this is great because like
I can just run this over and over again
and it will just never take up any time
but what happens if I reorder it because
I'm sort of a neat freak right so I want
my you know my adapter posit Ori to be
before my apt gets well that actually
breaks the cash it become it sees that
it has a blue to but it hasn't run these
commands in this order so then it has to
do all the same thing over again okay so
let's go back to our initial example
where we had three two images one with
ABC the other one is ABCD let's check
all the time this is the optimal way to
build these images right if if the nodes
on this graph are the commands being run
and the arcs where it says T of a and T
of B there's the time it takes then we
will incur every command exactly once
but if I structure it incorrectly then I
will incur ABC twice and D once which is
the worst case
important thing to note once two paths
have diverged never can they come
together again so if I think that I can
do this for generating a BD and a CD I
can't what will really happen is this
and I will incur the cost of D twice the
better way to do this would be to do ad
then split on B and C this would be my
optimal solution alright let's do a
problem formulation so let's okay what
are we trying to do we are trying to
take a set of docker files a set of
commands and structure them so that we
can make the most of the docker cash so
that we can use the least amount of
computing time to create these images so
that there's sort of a corollary between
maximizing use of the cash and
minimizing the amount of compute time
they're really the same thing so just
Invitational stuff let's start with C we
have a set of commands that we might run
each one of these commands has a you
know positive time that's that seems
reasonable we know Apriori the set of
images that we need to create sure also
like we probably know that times for
these commands or we can at least
estimate them I mean if we're we're
doing this every day or every week or
every month or something we could you
could time them we can look at the logs
we know how long it takes to build a
colonel whatever and C sub I is the
image is required for any I and in the
image set we're also going to define
this set P which is the will make a
little more sense in a bit it's it's the
set of images that have command applies
to and the commands that you run such
that you share the cash and we're going
to see that with single image command
pairs so for this example we have images
1 and 2 image one runs commands a B and
C and image two runs ABC and D so we're
just going to seed p with 1a 1b 1c so
what what is going to happen here we're
going to run each command for each image
and we're going to get our worst case
out right so that's we're going to
expect to see so for each one of these
things NP we define a binary decision
variable so it's either on or off if
it's on that we run that command for
so this is what that model looks like
we're trying to minimize the time it
takes to do it such that we do
everything the output is just ridiculous
we run every command for every image the
total time that it takes is two times
the first three x plus T of d and that's
what it looks like graphically so we're
starting at the worst case here how can
we improve it well we know that we share
a B and C through both the images so why
don't we create a variable for that so
we'll create a variable that says it if
it's one then run commands a B and C for
both images and it's 0 then don't so
then that can changes our constraints
because we can only run each command for
each image once so now x 1 sub a plus X
1 X sub 1 to ABC equals 1 so what's so
forth we have to make a choice between
these things right so this is our new
model and you can see this is pretty
much the addition to it is this plus EA
T sub BTW sub C times that new variable
and the constraints have changed so what
is the optimal solution to this one well
obviously oops it's that we share as
much as possible so we share a be the
commands a B and C for both images one
and two and for the one command that
image 2 has that image one doesn't we
run that so X sub 2 d is 1 and this is
our new this is our optimal time for
creating these images and that's what it
looks like rapidly so that's correct but
it's not unfortunately always so simple
let's consider this other case we have
four images to create three four five
and six and there's a lot more ways that
these can overlap for instance I could
you know overlap images three four and
six whitby I could do three four and
five with see I could do four and six
with D so and so forth right so I have
sort of initial stage decisions to make
and then decisions that depend on those
decisions right so if I share see
command C between 34 and five then I
might be able to share command be
between three and four or I might be
able to share command
see between three and five but only if I
do that because they have to be on the
same path so this is one possible
optimal schedule for that so here you
see I would share see for the first
three images and then share be for the
first two and then everything else would
be run for every image or if ta ta Bay
is large enough it could be this where I
actually share see between the first
three images or an A between the first
and the third or maybe d becomes very
large right and in terms of its time and
then all of a sudden I'm sharing d
between em just four and six so there's
a lot of different ways to go depending
on the data but let's say we we decide
to share see between the first three
images now what I do is I create new
variables that say let's assume that I
have shared see so I've made this
decision see for the first three I could
now share be or I could share a so these
are those are those two variables that
have created there that's why they've
got the super long subscripts but these
variables are dependent on that first
decision therefore they have to be less
than or equal to it it can only become
one if that other variable is one and I
just add these to my model and it will
do the right thing so if I know all the
right sets to generate then my model is
pretty easy to formulate and really it's
just an issue of like figuring out what
those sets are and restricting it to
make sure that they don't that you do
the correct thing so here's what I'd of
what it looks like mathematically it's
pretty simple looking all things
considered and if you've ever studied
any combinatorial optimization
literature this will look very familiar
but we'll get into a more into the
structure later so all we really need to
do is no PNR that's it right simple
alright so then the question becomes how
do we generate these these sets that
allow overlap or that allow sharing of
commands so this is this is where the
cheaters answer
because it's the answer that I can cover
in the time that we have the first thing
you do is you generate clicks right so
what is it click essentially we're
trying to do is is find sets that can
maximize our sharing at any level right
so maximum clique or maximal clique is
where eight let start with a leak a
click is a set of it's a graph where
every node every set of every pair of
nodes are connected right so here we see
that 52 and one arc leak five and one
are also a click but they're not maximal
because they're a sub click of 52 n 1 so
to generate all the cleats for this guy
I take all the images on the left and
all the commands on the right and I'd
connect them as they are already and
then I connect all my images and I can't
call my commands and then I just set
this up in Python so here we define our
commands the commands that it takes for
the images we're just gonna create some
times and we use network X and so this
outputs the following clicks these are
the top level ones and then if I wanted
to go create the dependency clicks I
would just run this again on things that
are left over so let's say we've made
that decision to use C to share see this
is the graph that is left over from that
I do the same procedure I just do this
again and again and so now I have these
variables which I just add to the
original model and as long as I've got
my dependency constraints correct it
will solve so the problem here is that a
click detection is np-complete so we
tend to kind of avoid things like that
right not necessarily you know it's
things are may be very intractable in
theory but real world data doesn't
necessarily look like that we tend to in
theory worry about pathological cases
and actually there are very good
algorithms for click detection and New
York leak detection that run pretty
quickly so I can I can deal with this
there are other techniques you can use
where you don't really need to generate
all of the data you could generate
enough of the the clicks that you know
your answer is going to be good enough
and you'll you'll improve pretty well it
just brings us to this section so once
we have our clicks we need to actually
put this all into a model we've got a
bunch of variables we've got something
that looks like a set partitioning
problem how do we solve that so we're
going to use the open source library
pulp which is an algebraic modeling
system if you haven't used it it's
really nice makes you makes it so you
don't really have to think about like
the matrix structure of a linear
optimizing a linear optimization problem
which is fun so what does the set
partitioning problem look like in pulp
basically looks like this you can either
minimize or maximize asset partitioning
problem and again set partitioning is
np-complete but we're just not going to
worry about that it's it's one of those
problems that's not solved in any way
but it is we're wicked good at solving
and people are set partitioning problems
we got heuristics that are excellent
we've got a pseudo-polynomial dynamic
programming problem algorithms for doing
it so we're just we're going to we're
going to use one NP hard problem to
generate the data for another NP hard
problem we're just gonna call it good so
this is what that looks like I'm going
to solve the the problem with the four
commands with or the four images each
with three commands so here we we just
create the the binary variables that
allow each image to run to incur the
cost of all of its commands and I know
the clicks because I just I ran the code
that we had so these are a bunch of
binary variables that allow us to do is
sharing this is sort of the top level of
that and then this is the secondary
level of that so these are the ones that
are dependent leaks these are the actual
dependency constraints and then this
restricts the intersections between them
you can write code to make this cleaner
but I think it's just a lot more obvious
if you just spell it out for
demonstration six all right so we add
constraints saying that each command or
each image runs each command exact
once and our objective here is to
minimize the compute time so that's the
time for each click we said our
objective run it and this is the output
so the time takes 67 whatever units of
time minutes seconds I don't know and
this is our schedule so this is not
immediately usable we have to construct
a skittle out of this but it tells us to
share a and C for images 3 & 5 & B and D
for images four and six and then
everything else just incur the cost for
the image so we construct that so we
share a b c and d and we just add the
other stuff at the end alright so let's
do it actual like computational example
this is generated data but yeah at some
point I'm going to go in docker hub and
maybe restructure some of their images
but for now so here we have a set of 15
images the commands are just numbers and
these are randomly selected and each one
has just a random amount of time these
could be seconds or minutes or hours and
we run it through our model and this is
the optimal contraction schedule so if
we just wrote our doc or files like this
we would make maximum use of cash and
our total time would be 9,000 414
alright so what does that mean right I
need something to compare it to so let's
come up with a heuristic so this is the
most common heuristic it's essentially
greedy at every stage let's just select
the most common image and move from
there or sorry the most common command
and move from there is really all it is
so I run that and i have another
schedule and we can see it's about ten
percent different but it does the same
thing but we just saved that amount of
time by optimizing optimizing fully now
this is also a lot better than you would
do if you just tried to run them but you
know there's a it's your gap between
heuristic and optimal solution so that's
about it I know I meant pretty quickly
over the optimization stuff I didn't
really want to talk too much about that
I think there's actually another talk
about that later today on the schedule
but
any questions yeah yeah yes yes right
you mean an existing one yeah yeah yeah
you could do that i would i would think
I would approach that in a the cost of
restructuring them approach as well like
like how if I if I if I change this
existing docker image that I have and I
move this command forward I have to run
everything after it and what is the cost
of doing that but yeah yes it does very
much though yeah any others all right
thank you